vous ne le verrez pas encore à l'écran
mais en nouveau rhinocéros blanc va
arriver au zoo de thoiry le 29 septembre
prochain son nom ouah kitty un mâle
blanc de 3 ans qui pèse une tonne il
provient du zoo de la boissière du doré
en loire-atlantique wac et y rejoindra
les deux autres rhinocéros déjà présent
dans le zoo les visiteurs bien entendu
vont découvrir en wac et y bientôt
puisqu'il va passer quelques jours un
petit peu isolé pourrait se faire à son
nouvel espace mais pas directement allé
dans sa loge et puis va rejoindre un
cercle bruno et unesco dans l'espace
réservé dans le coeur de la réserve ou à
kitty va remplacer numériquement vince
en 2018 seul rhinocéros avaient été
abattu de trois balles dans la tête et
braconné à l'intérieur de son enclos
pour sa corne malheureusement
la bêtise humaine encore une fois un
clairement qui a conduit à la mort de ce
rhinocéros depuis beaucoup de choses ont
été
encore plus renforcé en termes de
sécurité
encore plus dans cette zone là le
rhinocéros blanc fait partie d'une
espèce extrêmement menacée puisque il
n'en resterait que 20000 en milieu
naturel dans la zee la corne a des
vertus de force et de santé pour guérir
certaines choses on dit que ça guérit le
cancer ou genre de choses et ça peut
malheureusement conduire à tuer ce genre
d'animal pour juste récupérer un coup de
corne qui est vraiment encore une fois
que de la corne en france 62 rhinocéros
blanc visant parc zoologique